you've seen some actors lose their
you've seen some people that are
difficult to work with and how do you
deal with that I've had a couple of
experiences in the last 10 years and I
won't name any names because I don't
want to do that the hardest thing I
would say in the television world are
when actors show up and don't have their
lines down like at all it's so hard to
make these things the crew people
working you know one hour television
there's just nothing more brutal nothing
15-hour days like and then the crew on
top and that thing of just you know if I
could have a magic wand it would be we
all would have better memories or be
able to memorize lines better because I
think that really does so you remember
an incident or incidents where you know
someone didn't know their lines at all
and it was holding everybody up and they
they didn't care I mean I just it's
maybe a way of working I would say it's
something that ages me or shows that I'm
from a different thing where some people
just could get the lines just like that